i'm greg gutfeld i'm martha mccallum i'm
brett bear and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday may 18th 2022
i'm dave anthony inflation keeps pumping
up gas prices to record levels and
republicans keep urging president biden
to incentivize new oil drilling and
production and ease regulations instead
the administration's gone the other
direction they propose increasing
regulations on child care on housing
these are all things that are pinching
the personal incomes and the household
budgets of of rank and file americans we
speak with gop senator todd young
i'm lisa brady the mass shooting in
buffalo spurs renewed debate about red
flag laws these laws are necessarily
written in sort of broad terms because
it's hard to be specific as to
every possible
sign of violence
and i'm cole lyle and i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's something we're all dealing with
inflation we used to come here once a
week have breakfast do our shopping
now it's it's once a month
because it's a luxury i can't afford it
and it's not just the cost of her
breakfast at a diner in pennsylvania
record gas prices are changing shopping
habits i try to do everything in one
area if i'm coming here today okay what
can i hit in milford today walmart this
that and the other thing because after
this after today my shopping's done for
the week
no more go for a ride go here check this
out can't do it especially with regular
gas station wide averaging more than 450
a gallon even higher in pennsylvania
certain areas are
469 where i live it's 489 and it goes up
14 since yesterday it went up which is a
lot of money california has it the worst
now over six bucks for a gallon of gas
and record diesel prices are helping
raise the cost of food and many other
things we buy as i travel around indiana
this is the number one issue by far i
hear about senator todd young is a
republican from indiana it's a form of
taxation and of course it
disproportionately hits those on fixed
income so people of modest means and
our senior citizens so the wicked thing
about inflation is is once you're in an
inflationary environment it's very
difficult to find your way out of it
which is why you want to do everything
possible to avoid it and this could have
been avoided just about every republican
in the u.s senate i know was warning the
administration not to pass a 1.9
trillion dollar bill when our economy
was growing rapidly when they came into
office but they did and now we have
inflation so the administration needs to
forthwith indicate that they are no
longer supportive of
uh a green new deal far-left energy
policy
at least for the time being they need to
say we're going to open up the oil and
gas spigots domestically
and create incentives so that those who
who pull the oil and gas out of the
ground can build the infrastructure uh
to uh places where the oil and gas is
needed none of that is overnight so even
if you can increase drilling capacity uh
president biden says in his first year
there's more oil production than in the
first year of the trump presidency so he
says domestic oil we're producing a lot
he blames oil companies for not using
their leases and the president says
republicans are doing nothing to help
the gas price surge i mean that's that's
what he keeps saying yeah we should
import more things that are
more cost effective more inputs for our
manufactured products and so forth that
means reducing tariff barriers on some
of these items
in in the middle of an inflationary
environment we also need to lighten up
regulations something that we did during
the trump years and when republicans
were in control of congress instead the
administration's gone the other
direction they propose increasing
regulations on child care on housing
these are all things that uh are
pinching the personal incomes and the
household budgets of of rank and file
americans but the administration has not
offered regulatory relief they're going
the other direction senator young is up
for re-election this year and will face
democrat thomas mcdermott in november
young did not have a republican
challenger so there was no primary fight
at a time when former president trump is
having a big influence in primary races
nationwide shaping the gop agenda in the
attempt to take back republican control
of the house and senate we've been
locked in decades-old policy agendas the
far left has moved further to the left
over the last 40 years
the republican party was inattentive to
the needs of a lot of americans who felt
like they were being left behind in this
era of globalization and their
communities were being hollowed out
and so president trump spoke to a lot of
that aggravation it's now our job now
that president trump is no longer in
office
to write the next chapter of that script
and that's what i've done back in
indiana as i've spoken directly to these
concerns i've offered concrete solutions
to improving the material circumstances
of working americans
and that's uh what i attribute the fact
that i didn't have any primary uh
opponents to is the fact that uh i'm
actually out there offering constructive
solutions to these uh challenges that
president trump helped
uh you know exploit to uh political
victory now some have written about how
you were not yet endorsed by the former
president is that a con i mean you
obviously didn't have a primary is that
a concern to you at all
i think the proper narrative there is i
was able to stand on my own two feet i
think that's the headline that uh is is
worthy of
underscoring here uh which is you know
republicans can make their own name uh
they can build their own reputations and
their own
uh reservoir of trust with those people
they represent not have to rely on the
currency of former presidents uh if they
are putting forward concrete solutions
to today's and tomorrow's challenges
another big issue that leaked supreme
court draft opinion on abortion looking
like the conservative justices might
overturn the roe v wade ruling and let
states restrict abortion you at a
fundraiser recently faced pro-choice
protesters there was that vote in the
senate where there was not enough
support for the women's health
protection act the democrats put forward
to try to make abortion legal nationwide
where are we going with this issue and
how important is this one going to be in
the campaign in your view
you know with with inflation permeating
uh you know everyone's lives and and uh
border security such an incredible
challenge which in turn in my state is
leading to a a major
epidemic of uh opioid use
and
a war over in europe i'm not sure it
will play a really significant role in
my own state but it no doubt will in in
some areas around the country uh this is
an incredibly important issue where in
the end it's it's going to lead should
the supreme court publish this opinion
which we all believe they will which
will overturn roe versus wade is finally
the people will get to decide uh they
will be able to register their opinions
about how we properly balance
the concerns we all have
about women and their health and their
personal freedom on one hand
and the right to life of the unborn on
the other and these are not easy issues
but on the left they say look that you
the court's taking away a right that's
been
allowed for people for 50 years that's
the argument that the court is taking
freedoms away from women
of course they're saying that that's
that's a
reductive argument uh overlooking the
fact that
it will be through our state
legislatures and through the normal
democratic process and in consultations
with u.s senators and congress
men and women that will develop new laws
that will protect women and also protect
the unborn rather than having you know
our our unelected federal judges uh make
these laws for us so uh it's just going
to require some civic engagement from
the american people i i happen to have
faith in the people uh those on the far
left do not and i will say not every
democrat is a member of the far left we
saw this days ago when uh some of my
colleagues bravely said no i mean this
isn't saying this this uh pro-abortion
bill that was brought to the floor of
the u.s senate it would not only
enshrine roe versus wade in in federal
statute it would expand it uh up until
uh you know a short time before
birth and and and that really is extreme
another big issue is in the senate this
week more usaid for ukraine 40 billion
dollars worth of weapons and
humanitarian assistance some republicans
say it's too much gop senator bill
haggerty tells fox as senator paul said
we've got crises erupting across the
nation my home state mothers can't get
baby formula in knoxville you've got
grandmothers and mothers that have sons
and grandsons that won't come home
because of fentanyl overdoses because
the illegal drugs that are flowing
across our southern border that
president biden will not protect you've
got crime running rampant across america
but those objections were overruled by
other republicans joining democrats
monday night advancing the bill setting
up a final vote soon senator todd young
was among the yes votes i'm on record uh
saying time and again that that we need
to support the brave uh
and heroic resistance of the ukrainian
people
so that we can uh deter other aggressive
regimes around the world whether they're
in beijing or tehran or or moscow from
grabbing territory violating
uh the rules of the international order
because they will at some point look at
this and say if the united states and
the west are soft they'll move on other
pieces of real estate and that in turn
will impact our ability to trade our
ability to
peacefully carry out our affairs so with
that i i think that these monies um
there there's audit requirements reports
to congress diligent oversight need to
accompl accompany them and i was glad
that in the senate version of this
legislation as it's taken shape in
recent days
these
features uh have been embedded in the
legislation so we give ukraine money and
we make sure there are very strict audit
requirements and regular reports to
congress and and oversight mechanisms
all right last question you mentioned
beijing you
are working across the aisle with the
democratic leader of the senate chuck
schumer you have a bill
that would have the u.s working to
out-innovate and out-compete china
discuss
where we are on that i mean we've had
tariffs in place since the trump era and
they're still in place correct
we have that's right we had tariffs in
place we put some export controls in
place during the trump era and what
we're trying to do is make sure that we
have the necessary investments outside
of the dod where they waste so much
money
but the necessary investments and
cutting-edge technologies so that uh we
can out-fight the chinese communist
party if ever necessary hopefully we can
prevent a war uh by being more
technologically sophisticated than they
are we see in russia they're using
hypersonic weapons the chinese have
tested
advanced hypersonic missiles we don't
have defenses for these things we also
need computer chips any auto assembler
in the state of indiana can tell you
that because they don't have enough to
assemble all the automobiles that uh
our consumers are asking for we cannot
rely on communist china or other
countries for these computer chips
anything with an on off switch requires
them including our missile technology so
incentives to locate these chip
fabrication plants across the heartland
of america will also be included in this
legislation would this also potentially
lead to more pharmaceutical products
being developed here and manufactured
here would this lead to more
manufacturing in the u.s less in china
ultimately it would lead to more
manufacturing in the u.s and and less in
china
as a byproduct of this legislation
that's not the primary purpose but it
will be
something you know when we're developing
the cutting edge technologies here
then you're going to have investors
wanting to invest in production capacity
next to where the technologies are
developed so in that sense yes it will
republican senator todd young from
indiana thank you very much for joining
us thank you dave
this is cole isle with your fox news
commentary coming up
while an 18 year old awaits his next
court appearance accused of targeting
black shoppers in western new york
president biden and the first lady paid
a visit to buffalo on tuesday phil and i
have come to stand with you
and to the families we've come to grieve
with you the president meeting with
victims families and paying tribute to
their loved ones by name saturday's
supermarket shooting that left ten dead
and three wounded remains under
investigation but police say the suspect
peyton gendron appears to have been
racially motivated posting a lengthy
manifesto in america evil will not win i
promise you
hate will not prevail
and white supremacy
will not have the last word the
president also calling again for keeping
assault weapons off streets new york
governor kathy hokel calling for a
national gun policy police say the
buffalo suspect had a gun he purchased
legally but modified it you couple that
with an illegal magazine from another
state you brought in literally minutes
away in pennsylvania you know easy that
is there were potential red flags about
gendron months before the manifesto last
year he was investigated for a potential
threat against his high school but state
police say in the end no one requested
taking firearms away from gendron and
new york's red flag law which could have
stopped him from buying more weapons was
not used the problem with these red flag
laws
is that they're a very sound approach to
dealing with some of these cases of
mental illness but they require
an intervention jonathan turley is a fox
news contributor and law professor at
george washington university they
require someone to pick up the phone
and to notify authorities because at the
end of the day you need a judge
who's going to issue this order
and that is a process that works well if
someone is institutionalized
particularly for a longer period of time
it works less well if you have
a shorter term duration events or
episodes like this one where someone is
investigated but ultimately no action is
taken
so the red flag laws are only as good as
people put them to use
somebody at the end of the day has to
call up
the police and say i have a concern that
this is an individual who could be a
danger to himself or to others
yeah i mean
constitutionally
how broad
can these laws be in other words you
know how specific do the threats or
actions of the person need to be
in order for these laws to come into
play or does it really vary that greatly
by state
well all these laws have a fairly
ambiguous standard dealing with someone
who is believed to be a risk to himself
or to others
the protection is the involvement of a
court who is
going to be looking at the underlying
allegations the thing to keep in mind is
that this is the suspension of a
constitutional
individual right and so under cases like
heller you have a right to possess
weapons
so you do need that court order
but in terms of what is necessary to
trigger it these laws are necessarily
written in sort of broad terms because
it's hard to be specific as to
every possible
sign of violence and instead these are
laws that leave it to a court to
determine whether someone should be
temporarily denied possession of weapons
because there is a reasonable belief
that they present a danger to themselves
or to others
i mean if
one of these laws is triggered if you
will how complicated is the process to
get your guns back or to clear your name
does that vary by state as well it does
and it can be difficult because once you
lose those weapons the burden is on you
to show that
you are no longer a risk
that can be something that is challenged
the same people that
raise the issue can express ongoing
concerns once somebody has
their possession of weapons suspended or
removed there is a practical presumption
that this is someone who has been a risk
and therefore may continue to be a risk
so i think it is fair to say that once
you lose possession under these laws
you do have a burden that can be
difficult administratively to shoulder
but once again you know these laws as we
get these cases going to court
we're going to see i think a further
articulation of these standards because
at the end of the day you were still
talking about suspending someone's
individual constitutional rights
have
these laws been facing a lot of legal
challenges so far
they have but some of the laws that have
been challenged
are sort of offshoots of this you know
the red flag laws are really designed to
quickly
remove weapons from someone who may be a
risk to themselves or to others
there are other states that have more
onerous requirements in terms of getting
these types of weapons back there's also
laws
that bar people that have criminal
convictions even convictions that may be
misdemeanors so all of those types of
laws have generated some litigation
but in terms of red flag laws themselves
i think that constitutionally they're
pretty solid i think that even
those people who are strong advocates of
the second amendment
tend to agree that you can have your
possession of weapons suspended the
disagreement is just simply
the standard that has to apply it's not
enough for someone to simply say i think
this person is a danger there's got to
be some articulable
basis for that now in this case you had
a question of a threat but if there is a
record that was inconclusive as to
whether a threat had been made that's
probably not going to be sufficient for
most police departments to move to
suspend weapons on the other hand if you
have somebody who clearly made threats
acted in an unstable way that probably
will be sufficient at least for a
temporary suspension
the us supreme court has an upcoming
decision on a new york gun law it
requires someone to show proper cause in
order to get a concealed carry permit so
to legally carry a hidden weapon in
public the new york mayor has been
expressing concern about what the court
might do especially after the leaked
draft opinion on abortion
how significant could this concealed
carry ruling be
in terms of the bigger picture on gun
rights nationwide
well this is one of the matinee cases of
the term it is a case that really most
people put in the top three in terms of
its implications
the reason is that it's been a while
since the court handed down a major
decision on gun rights
you had the heller decision which
defined
the second amendment as an individual
right of possession of gun ownership you
had mcdonald
which extended that right to the states
and you
have a very strong and robust statement
supporting the second amendment so the
new york case
is really the next generation that many
of us have been looking at that is to
what extent can you restrict collateral
rights
collateral issues related to gun
ownership including a concealed weapon
i expect that the court will rule
against new york and will
further strengthen the second amendment
the new york law
basically requires people to show good
cause to have a concealed
weapon
and
there's this question of why a lawful
gun owner needs to prove
that they have the sort of moral
standing and the good cause to have a
weapon in public
does
or should the supreme court treat all
cities
and jurisdictions the same in terms of
gun rights for instance do your gun
rights change if you enter or live in a
densely populated area
i think the court wants to see
uniformity for citizens and being able
to
carry weapons
absent some extreme or special showing
and so i think you may see this shifting
of a burden but i think it will bring
greater uniformity because right now
there is a patchwork of laws governing
concealed weapons and this case may
create
a single unified standard
the plaintiffs in this case
are a shoot a new york shooting club
that had a case the year before
and that involved a law that the new
york politicians passed and stated with
great bravado that they were going to
take this all the way to the supreme
court
and the supreme court said fine and
accepted
uh certiorari accepted review
and after the case was accepted and
argued new york suddenly decided to
rescind the law and just basically pull
out of the case
and it irritated many of the justices
who felt that new york was gaming the
system that they were telling voters one
thing but when it came time to actually
review the law which many of us viewed
as unconstitutional they just pulled the
rug out there was a statement made by a
few of these justices saying we will
bide our time but we think we should
have just gone ahead and ruled on this
law well
they then accepted a case by the very
same plaintiff organization
and so i think in some ways new york
could not have played this worse
one other question
about existing gun laws and that is
california's ban on semi-automatic
sales to people under age 21 recently
struck down by a federal appeals court
but the court allowed the state to keep
requiring a hunting license to buy
shotguns or rifles if you're under 21
not in the military or law enforcement
what signal does that send to states or
is it just another you know example of
the patchwork of gun laws across the
country
well there has been a long tradition for
hunting licenses because that is
not just the possession of a weapon but
an activity that has been regulated
historically
what
really the court was balking at in
california is once again this isolation
of particular
guns and limiting who can have them the
key here is that these are all people
over 18 they are adults
and they were being denied the ability
to have
these assault-like weapons
the problem is that the ar-15 is the
most popular rifle in the united states
the reason is that it tends to be module
modular that is you can
change it you can change the
configuration of it that's what makes it
so popular with so many gun owners
and
the states get into trouble when they
try to ban particular types
of weapons many of the weapons that
california doesn't try to limit have a
higher
caliber
so we once again get to the political
dynamic here a lot of politicians
particularly in california in texas
you've had this issue come up of we're
going to ban a salt-like weapons and
when they get the court the courts say
well why i mean why are you banning this
particular weapon and not this one over
here
what's different about this other than
how it looks
and that has been a real problem the
states have not been able to make out
that case
jonathan turley george washington
university law professor and fox news
contributor thank you very much for your
time
thank you
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
cole lyle
what's on your mind as president biden
considers for giving student loan debt
there are important factors to consider
including the impact on our military and
veterans who earned opportunities to
pursue an affordable college education
for most veterans the choice to join the
military was foremost about serving our
country but for many it was also about
receiving benefits to attend college
without debt
earning the gi bill meant giving up
years of their lives serving in
dangerous jobs and situations
the student loan debate is leaving out
the impact cancellation will have on the
veteran and active duty community
that's probably why in a recent mission
roll call poll of 6 202 veterans 77
opposed student loan forgiveness
college is expensive and it's only
getting pricier but since an
undergraduate degree even if unrelated
to one subsequent career has become a
barrier to entry for most professional
career tracks
most prospective students feel like they
have no other option
they become saddled with student loans
that don't go away in bankruptcy and can
delay important life events like buying
a home or having children but there has
always been a path to free higher
education for over 80 years military
service and the gi bill have enabled
millions of americans to pursue college
debt free or nearly free
serving the military and the federal
government will help ensure you have the
resources necessary for success without
burdensome debt
already in college join the rotc
in the military and want to use the gi
bill for grad school use tuition
assistance
not sure what you want to do out of high
school enlist and earn your gi bill
already have a degree or want to make
the military your career transfer the gi
bill to your kids
i joined the marine corps two weeks out
of high school deployed to afghanistan
and earned my degree using the gi bill
i know firsthand the sacrifices service
members made to earn that benefit
they all made a choice
in most cases joining the military meant
receiving the gi bill and the chance to
go to school for little to no cost they
earned that opportunity
every year hundreds of thousands of
americans earn the gi bill as an
incentive for their service
it isn't something freely given and it
isn't something any civilian can feel
entitled to
for veterans and active troops who want
to pursue a debt-free education through
honorable service policies that forgive
student loan debt minimize their efforts
and experiences
canceling student debt is a nuanced and
complex policy proposal worthy of debate
and yet like many broad policies the
veteran community could be affected by
unintended consequences
joining the military is not the only way
to attend college but it's a vital
option for service members who want a
degree without having to saddle
themselves with tens of thousands of
dollars of debt
it was certainly the right of those who
chose not to serve to find different
options but it should not be at the
literal and figurative expense of those
who served our nation
serving in uniform takes commitment and
courage and as our nation's leaders
discuss student loan forgiveness we hope
they adequately consider the
life-changing decisions service members
make for our country and honor their
service in this debate i am cole isle
executive director of mission roll call
and a marine corps veteran
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes